my fear and I think it's a very real
fear is that as we continue to produce
all of these processed versions of meat
and dairy products that are tasting
better and better and better that people
that are entering into becoming vegan
can easily just be eating all sorts of
refined grains all the time and cookies
and snacks and things like that and
they're you know they're like hey I'm
vegan it's healthy when in fact it
perhaps might even be worse than
whatever they were doing before yes
absolutely so I think once you figure
out what the science and all these
pillars are saying go back to your
grandparents table and among the healthy
things pick the ones that were common at
their table or not so if you do that
then I think you're guaranteed
especially if you go with the
grandparents or great grandparents that
you're going to eliminate a lot of these
these new processed foods that you're
talking about so I mean I don't think
there are many too many grandparents
that ate processed foods in the past